whoa just in time and I didn't get to
eat my granola bar okay there's a half
hour coming up a hundred players
two-minute tournament warzone or no it's
not it's the chest cube meltdown Oh back
just in time that was too close
all right and if 696 possibility still
for fishing poles I'm gonna try it
I know oh I still go with this okay
let's open this up Darkstar bishop I
don't have to worry about light-square
weaknesses big light-square weaknesses
uh-oh and just Knight right here that
was stupid of me I could have trapped
the rook as well
it's queenside castle g5 ah I got the
rook are they gonna resign less than 30
minutes
of course there's less than 30 minutes
Oh Captain Obvious is in the house here
less than 30 minutes Wow yeah thanks for
that one right you really needed to know
that it's a 30 minute tournament of
course it's gonna be less than 30 okay
Queen right here trade Queens mm-hmm
okay rook takes and come on I'm up the
full rook let's get this guy out of here
get developed get my rook over and let's
go King do something do something here
come on up sneak up here grab this pawn
and then get the other one going back up
right here is good enough get rid of the
block hater let's do this bishop here
next could have been taken but I could
have just pushed or something
wish I could have taken the rook as well
with check they're down harder they're
out they resigned back to tournament 5-3
and a couple twos Knapp 3e for for the
win I seem to always play against this
guy I don't know if it's always and no
it's actually more in two minute games
so what is this this is a French and you
know what I'm gonna go with that idea I
was expressing earlier let's see if I
can make this happen
Oh
what's the scoop here that's the scoop
huh
let's take here and then take where take
on c5 and then get my Bishop on this
diagonal uh-oh there could be some
tricks tough tricky stuff trick stuff
tricky stuff coming up
mmm let's try that not quite sure what
it's doing but his f6 gonna be played
there's still some stuff with home in
stop that night from doing some stuff
here um Knight back here I think I want
to play I want to get that move in right
now I backup please just take that Queen
us to go elsewhere maybe some Queen move
let's try this I'm on h7 okay now I'm on
what it's right new mate
the bishop could block let's come back
here Knight takes Knight possibly um
it's a bit scary over here actually okay
we're gonna have the Queen's come off
and my King I think wants to be right
here why did I do that move okay I want
my pawns on dark squares ideally what's
the clock situation I want one pair of
Brooks to come off and that's it just
one now let's come over here a file can
open
I'm gonna take towards the center as the
pound gonna push the pond pushes okay I
don't know what I'm doing now actually
let's get this guy going here mm-hmm
can I get this in pond push a couple
times one two push it again
let me do this before that move comes I
don't want to okay wait I have an idea
maybe change a direction I want my king
to get to d4 I think this is a right
idea might as well take my king and
fortunately I have this square covered
if I didn't have it covered I'm in some
trouble and maybe I could even do
without this pond I think it could
actually push it do this I want to keep
that F pond around how much time gotta
get this one this is an important game
here oh there's that move okay let's
come over here if you wanna draw I don't
want to I wanna win no come on
am i pressing my luck here I'm gonna
sneak my king in oh now I might not get
this guy maybe I have a past pond I have
a good uh blockade here with my king
let's come back target that pond in
which way this isn't a good way catch
them in a pre move maybe free move yeah
three moves I'm gonna push and then ah
King position I'm gonna give a check or
just take that pounder running out of
time here
King position I can actually grab the
bishop and then they have to give the
bishop up actually then I get these two
pawns this guy and then this guy and
then back determine okay eleven eleven
nine sixes here we go twenty three
minutes and change Rhino nine to six
five
okay let's roll here
my opponent isn't movin f3 we just went
over this why is f3 not a good idea
uh-oh ready chop that Knight up maybe d5
wasn't a good idea either okay this is
some serious serious serious problem
here
Queen check here leading to some
annoying stuff okay my opponents
stopping that Bishop out I get the pawn
no I don't want to trade Queens maybe I
do let's come here I want to get my dark
script Bishop out we're gonna get it out
here let's do this and then this pawn
could be taken but I want to get a
bishop right here what's going on it's a
little scary action oh I should have
just pushed I'm helping develop my
opponent's pieces here let's trade after
all after all that after all that I'm
gonna take this pond it's poison poison
pawn the rook gets trapped after Knight
here or does it it wouldn't get trapped
Oh blunders blunders blunders
miscalculations after miscalculations on
this pond maybe getting the rook soon
somehow pawn push I get this guy or just
get him for free
resignation drop the rook there's no
good solution there's that frog it's
still in my throat here I can't shake it
sorry about that rook up
you
I don't meet the stream right there oh
it's it's my move I missed that out of
that last move by my opponent that night
getting in Forks and stuff oh I'm still
in a fork I'm threatening a fork though
let's play right here easy does it
Bishop takes I'm in a fork okay I have
material to do that okay I'm getting hit
with forks or mi okay let's go after
that night Wow
to start out like that where I shattered
the structure and the Queen's around the
board how silly silly silly silly
let's go tonight I need to get that
night I guess a four so the knight has a
support point on b5 okay that's good and
I'm actually just gonna take it because
I have basically connected passed pawns
and these guys could all drop I'm just
gonna do that for fun just so there's no
sneaky pawn rooms and this guy's past so
let's get him going and let's get him
going still
let's go King position or just push the
pun okay they resigned back to
tournament 29:24 13 okay what's the
scoop here I can need to get a quick win
come on where the quick wins those are
all real slow let's try this
get some center maybe throw a fourth
pawn into the mix why not launch it each
pond let's go let's roll here oh let's
get the h-file open up queenside castle
what are they doing with their pawns
here let's take one and then push
forward this squares available for a
knight I could take them though maybe g4
eventually Queen f2 g4 with tempo might
be even better actually I'm gonna do g4
now let's do this and take on f6 and
then Queen takes east six is uh is a
threat actually g3 I should be doing no
I'm not gonna take that pun actually
shut up why not
I had a knight g5 to follow I could
still play Knight g5 this is still I
think pretty good queenside castle
double up on the H file there was
something more direct I should have done
with that let's do it now take and after
the rook blocks there's Queen here it's
not really leading anywhere though is it
there's gonna be Queen move here the
Queen's come off and then I'm in check
and then the rook reacts man oh well oh
no I could have just taken the rook no I
couldn't I was in a pen I'm missing a
lot of stuff here
ah no quick wins at all where are the
quick wins they come late do I start off
slow and then I win later where do I
start off slow and I won't win it all
later ah what's this guy doing to take
here and then I could take on h7 after
the knight takes and what is the scoop
here pawn push take here and I get the
bishop in less than a minute what's this
Knight up to no don't you dare I want to
get my bishop where my bishop wants to
get to e5 with check war my pond my pawn
wants to get to g5 maybe and now I want
to go here check and I get the night the
night has to go back or something this
is close to me very very close to me all
right resign time come on this is beat
isn't it check where's the main
I want to give a check here and then run
it my past pun that should be clean
enough I'm on the bishop let's do this
and run my Bishop on e5 oh come on this
is B don't you be known to fry and stuff
ah oh man this is a killer this is a
killer right here I guess you're just
gonna let their clock tick they're not
resigning you if they're gonna resign
they're they're gonna do it mate - if
the King goes to the center I just can't
let any of my clock tick that's what
it's coming down to play here and then
Queen then it's me maybe one two three /
soon there might be B for something to
delay it back to tournament that took
forever forty one thirty twenty eight
twenty three twenty twenty sixteen and
change night Hawker
let's go hawk let's do this come on
let's um let's get the hawk with the
fishing pole I'm going fishing for the
hawk oh oh let's see about development
hope to see a night to see 400 a hook a
hook a hook let's do this I could take
with check it's important to know
there's tactics on b5 when you make a
move like this be very aware of that
king each one or that okay pins I guess
I'm in trouble it's gonna be a pawn push
isn't there I gotta go run it away okay
now I could at least safely defend
against t5i I messed that up
f4 was a good move it's Castle there's
no sneaky fishing poles in this position
okay let's let's trade a little bit and
take my bishop okay now I could do this
I'm out of the line of fire and here we
go plant this rook right here and take
take them
this is a good support point for a rook
I might have to stop okay this now
there's light-square weaknesses here
actually that night I need to you need
to make a decision before you bother me
okay I hear is it going to be taken I'm
gonna take with what
okay I'm gonna actually play here it's a
nice square hitting everything pawns
Bishop rook right here and that pawn is
falling isn't it okay this could be real
brutal real fast to check on g3 right
it's gonna be game over Bishop takes I
take here and then there's material loss
oh the whole family is being hit right
now that one hurts come on back to
tournament thirty fifty five forty
thirty I have five games in top guy
seven and then the second guy six okay
let's do this because it's there's still
possibilities for the fishing pool
unless of Bishop f5 move is played okay
I'm gonna trap the bishop okay now let's
do this and then and then what to trade
and then get in even though this is my
my good Bishop what I'm looking to get
is what I'm looking to get no you just
stay there Bishop I don't want to I
don't want to go in that direction so
how about I get an f5 maybe that was a
stupid idea actually I want to get an f5
though that five kicked that bishop away
and then develop my knight or maybe play
b5 to stop Knight a5 stuff first let's
do that and then get developed maybe
Knight a four to c5 I still have this
move in mind
okay I'm winning some material
eventually there's pressure on this
point so that's why I couldn't go after
the f5 palm but now I'm on b7 and if
there's take I'm going to capture
towards the Sun otherwise there's the
possibility for a pawn push
then Queen to d5 now I'm I am on this
point let's pinpoint this punt rip to b6
I think is good lateral movement and I
think there's something with g4 although
Knight a5 is going to be a bit
disruptive now this is all the more
appealing pawn push then this file opens
up this is a problem worked right into a
pin this is a move I was going to do
anyhow what's the scoop here my Queens
gonna come back here and then over to h2
being sneaky with this move I want to
swing over laterally and now
why can't it be easy let me take here
this is not this is not working out good
uh I did this wrong that pawns just
gonna push oh I'm doing the wrong punt
I'm doing the wrong Kahn moves I'm not
crashing through here oh this is painful
oh this is very painful okay just let
the Queen's come off I think that's my
best case scenario here ah how horrible
is that I have something I floundered
why am i floundering okay I could get
this still stop the knight move here
Knight move here it's safe stay active
rook um King up be a fighter King no I
like my rook too much 45 seconds each
and it just can't be easy can it uh I'm
gonna do this I want to stay active I
need to keep my rook around I need an
active rook okay active rook and the
stupid bishop that's perfect to work
with right now what a team an active
rook and a stupid bishop that's looking
to start to do something here soon hit
the rookie get active Bishop give a
check kill a knight stay active Bishop
what's the scoop I got the night I got
the Jeep on
I got me no I don't maybe I do it's
close to it it's real close give a check
give a check now the king look at the
king he's a fighter
Oh snuck away oh man why did I allow
that to happen
he was sneaky that King scarred here
Oh miscalculation in time pressure
this guy's fast my seat pond is really
fast
oh but their pond is fast too
okay I got this covered just in the nick
of time
oh no time
anything anything back to tournament Oh
ten okay seventy one fifty four forty
two I don't have Bo the dog Bo the dog
is playing as white okay Queen c7 knight
c6 b5
ah Bishop e7 and maybe there's something
with this g5 or something let's try this
direction you're gonna open that up
actually I should try this d5 move first
let's get this and see how my opponent
is reacting okay let's go with this
the knight is ready to land right here
on f6 let's stop that night right here
is a good move - are they gonna open up
the H file forming night right here is
what I want to do get the light-square
bishop and then kill white on g2 maybe
they're not moving I'm not getting any
quick wins there's only nine minutes
left 135
I guess night here or something ah
where are the quick wins
maybe g5 just to get this pine I got to
stop that night I think give up my dark
square bishop to do it but alright let's
do it let's do this and not quite sure
why but okay my my queen wants to get
this
maybe there's gonna be stuff happening
over here there we have it positions
opening up but this pond is gonna be
past 1 minute 8 pond push this file can
open up my king is on it maybe I want to
do this instead Oh mate one threat
you're gonna see it don't see it take my
night he's free to free night actually
has to be taken there's a queen trapped
sneaky and hid this night and what what
else I'm on the pond as well that night
can't move if it moves that's it jeetu
I'm gonna keep her up there the night
pressure the queen is constrained g2 is
the plan might be a pawn push just to
get Queen takes pawn or even like a
queen check here if I take with my Jeep
on there are no quick wins in this game
no quick resign errs Oh seven minutes
and change can I somehow come back less
than 20 oh it's not happening 15 14 13
and there is a tournament right after
this that I will be jumping right into
it's a 1-minute er oh just a clock
ticker what's going on with these clock
tickers looking for me I should have
just taken the night can I get me
quicker than two seconds from I'm just
gonna do it even if it's wrong back to
chairman 5689 7056 5625
have this pond make up its mind what are
you gonna do pond support or take or
push okay take now dark squares I want a
knight on f6 but after the dark square
Bishop scum off how can I get a knight
there
I'm not sure my rook wants to be on c1
this Bishop wants to be here because
it's annoying to that rook and now
there's no castling or is there let's
play here Knight c4 Knight c1 dark
square weaknesses everywhere so what
does that mean it means the Queen should
be maybe playing to a dark square okay
sneak up here how does my knight get
there let's stop castling for a bit I
guess there's gonna be that move isn't
there oh man okay let me do what castle
if they Castle they're crazy
Queen Queen h6 let's do that dark square
control is still here I might want to
take that night and then Queen here
let's double up double rooks eventually
something has to be done with that King
make a decision black King ah
interesting
interesting idea right there very nice
okay let's trade I guess very nice
slick move there with the King ah and
game land I'm knocking anything fast
okay I get a good square for my Knight
bishops hit I get material here I get
something out of this but still down on
time and only five minutes left in the
tournament I need three quick resign
errs can we get three cries I hit the
bishop hit this pawn and drop this one
at the same time take this one don't -
error actually don't take that one
because he's not free or anything b5
it's not a free pawn is it it's only
been there for three moves oh man
43 seconds get to square for my knight
dark squares are still under control
maybe I should have played f4 my
opponent is flying here I gotta go
quicker there's gonna be a knight check
okay my my knight wants to be somewhere
else right here is a wonderful square
oh I just dropped upon no I'm on the
roof though let's watch over this Czechs
maids coming up mates looking for the
mates looking for the forks forks back
rank me it's pigs on the second seventh
you know what I meant
pigs pigs run with the pon-pon push
there's me they resigned back to
tournament 129 once 129 72 72 I'm
looking for a second can I get a second
oh man
I only have how many games in okay you
could do this don't you dare give up
come on Castle just Castle everything's
gonna be wonderful as soon as you castle
Oh taking away my main man here he's my
main man I need this guy around he's not
he's the worm I just got rid of the worm
right here
okay let's expand on this side oh but
maybe I have something else to say
maybe my LightSquared bishop wants to do
some damage oh there could be big
trouble soon h4 h3 light square
weaknesses I have to get one more this
is gonna be the last game it's Castle if
I'm lucky if this even gets in okay
they're ready to take my night out
Oh Oh going down in flames light square
weaknesses that's mate back to
tournament 90 can I hold second place
129 92 minutes 40 I need two or three
quick resign as if I could win first
quick resign quick mate
come on should I even be doing this I
just keep it opened I need to go for
like a made on f7 or something I have to
try ridiculous stuff at this point oh
what's happening with this Bishop c4 I
want to be on that square Bishop takes
pawn as a threat be aware of it mate
threat in two or one something close to
it move the knight here it's okay
oh it just can't be easy can a matin -
threat just take the pond just take the
pond he's free that's a main - isn't it
just move king just move just move just
move
don't let your clock tick oh no don't
you dare be a clock tick err yes back to
term at 110 129 110 135 come let's go
quick resigns - quick resigns 1 minute
30 can I get two more wins no no no a
mouse lip you can't win if your mouse
slipping oh ok have the F file maybe can
I get one more in this nights ready to
give me a beating and the clean age 5
stuff get this pine target F till after
I Castle Oh
hit the night are they gonna miss it oh
I'm gonna allow for it go ahead move
here Knight go I'd still move there
protect your bishop it's gonna be ok
just move here you get the rook you get
the rope yes do it take my rope take my
brother take my Brook he's free I
promise he's free he's free I'm not
threatening made on f - they see it they
sniffed it out ah they sniffed it out I
get material at the end of it oh come on
you know you want to take a look he's
freeze a free piece on f8 yes they
resigned back to tournament one thirty
twenty two seconds what happened what
happened
Oh somebody slipped up Oh what's
happening I have a one-point lead oh my
goodness how did this happen
no way can I try it quick win no I just
saw my queen I just have to burn the
time I need time burners don't let me
don't make me finish this game don't you
dare make me finish this game it's
saying it's complete it's saying it's
complete look at what did I get what did
I get what the ticket
I was so close so close all right at the
last second I guess there was a win good
games Oh
139 139 t8 a little glimmer of hope
right at the end oh there must have been
a buzzer-beater right there good games
all